good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1427 object
class Keter special containment
procedures as CP 14:27 is to be
contained on-site at the room young
containment Operations Center our COC
operated by the foundation in
partnership with the Korean People's
Army kPa due to the artifacts effects
foundation personnel are not to enter
the DPRK approach to within 130
kilometers of the SCP 1427 exclusion
zone or attempt to interact daily with
the object itself foundation personnel
are to provide remote support to on-site
DPRK personnel under no circumstances
our foundation personnel to attempt to
dissuade kPa containment staff from
incorrect or unusual beliefs concerning
the nature of their duties at the our
COC or the nature of their national
government as authoritarian submissive
personality traits provide conditional
immunity to the signal broadcast by the
artifact foundation personnel assigned
to off-site monitoring must meet the
following psychological testing criteria
standardized Milgram compliance panel
greater than 71 IP IP openness panel
less than 39 rwa authoritarian
submission panel greater than 17 and RWA
conventionality panel greater than 31 at
present only three national governments
possess citizens with conditioning
suitable for containment of SCP 14 27
the Republic of Turkmenistan the
republic of the union of Myanmar
and the Democratic People's Republic of
Korea or DPRK for short of the three
suitable containment areas political
issues render North Korea the only
government suitable for long-term
containment accordingly embedded
foundation affiliates in UN Security
Council member states shall take no
action tending to destabilize the DPRK
promote democratization or permit the
entry of psychologically unsuitable
foreigners into the 600 metre red zone
surrounding the Rinne young complex in
the event of democratization
destabilization or nuclear war
foundation intergovernmental liaisons
shall attempt to transfer the object to
a designated secondary containment site
in the event that no secondary
containment sites are available the
primary containment site and its
surrounding environment are to be
thermally sterilized using non-nuclear
force without regard to the risk of
civilian casualties using presently
available techniques thermal
sterilization of Pyongyang and
surrounding environs there's a 91%
chance of containment failure
catastrophic containment failure is
predicted to constitute an EK class
event resulting in the extinguishment of
all human consciousness within
approximately 215 days description SCP
1427 is a featureless 14 by 2 by 2 metre
beryllium bronze steel though originally
recovered in an inactive state the
artifact presently produces a
directional electromagnetic pulse every
7 nanoseconds disrupting or jamming the
pulse reduces but does not eliminate the
artifacts primary effect the device's
electromagnetic effects are therefore
theorized to be a carrier wave for or
side-effect of the devices primary
function targets are selected randomly
from the 20,700 36:12 to the power of 4
nearest human subject ignoring those
already exhibiting the effects of the
pulse budding
those who are immune the device appears
to have no effective maximum range on
several occasions the device has
exhibited the ability to make
over-the-horizon broadcasts to otherwise
occluded subjects by deflecting its
signal off of the Earth's ionosphere the
artifacts means of detecting human
consciousness and the causative
mechanism underlying its effects are
presently unknown upon receipt of the
signal subjects permanently experience
increased suggestibility severe abuela
and short-term memory loss these effects
are secondary to the artifacts primary
effect which is substantial reduction in
prefrontal sq2 signal due to information
recovered from SCP foundation
researchers presently believe that this
reduced sq2 signal corresponds to a
significant reduction in or total
destruction of the subjects subjective
consciousness moderate authoritarian
submissive personality traits appear to
provide conditional immunity to the
effects of the broadcast accordingly
since its activation containment
protocols have required placement in
high population density areas subject to
a totalitarian government SCP 1427 was
originally recovered from a Cistercian
monastery in southeastern algeria by
italian special forces in january of
1938 laboratory notes from that period
mention a rhodium carbide outer casing
embossed with lettering in a known but
poorly characterized Semitic alphabet
that outer casing is presumed to have
been destroyed or lost by Italian
researchers before the objects
transferred to Leipzig in 1944 between
1938 and 1944 the governments of Germany
and Italy attempted to activate the
artifact both without success in the
immediate aftermath of World War 2 the
object was kept in East German custody
the East German government took no
recorded action with respect to the
artifact
in 1947 the East German government
transferred SCP 1427 to Soviet control
who moved it to kyshtym Chelyabinsk
Oblast USSR in September of 1957 Soviet
researchers intentionally activated as
CP 14:27 though the artifact affected
human targets in its immediate
surroundings then existing features of
the Soviet government prevented the EK
class and of human consciousness after
attempted nuclear sterilization of the
affected area the Soviet government
contacted the foundation through
intergovernmental liaisons and the
artifact was transferred to foundation
custody at site 67 southwest of chernev
Ukraine since initial containment the
artifact has only been transferred once
in 1986 due to predicted instability in
the Soviet government the artifact was
transferred to the Democratic People's
Republic of Korea shortly thereafter the
foundation commenced construction of the
room young containment facility where
the object has been stored since its
completion in 1988 addenda SCP 14:27 ET
r3 ethics committee dissent SCP 1427 on
December 5th 1991 a nine member panel of
the SCP foundation ethics committee
decided after a two for three plurality
vote to actively support the government
of the Democratic People's Republic of
Korea North Korea in order to effectuate
containment of SCP 1427 in summary the
deciding plurality found the following
points in favor of limited stabilization
and support in stability and increasing
political openness may soon render the
USSR unsuitable for containment of a-c-p
14:27 in the event of political
instability in North Korea the device
may be safely transferred to the custody
of the People's Republic of China or
Indonesia North Korea's closed borders
limit the risk of exposing foreigners
and due to limited trade
opportunity's foundation affiliates and
liaisons are better able to manipulate
North Korean internal policy toward
effective containment despite the clear
benefits of the above we dissent
experimentation has demonstrated that as
CP 1427 requires no more than 12 ^ 4
psychologically suitable individuals in
close proximity to the object in order
to maintain seamless containment with
that in mind maintaining over 20 million
individuals in a state of perpetual
involuntary totalitarian objection is an
unacceptable cost to impose on human
subjects while it is clear that in 1957
doing so was a necessary accession to
certain facts on the ground viz Soviet
failure to destroy the object outright
the foundation has recruited nine
thousand seven hundred and twenty four
d-class candidates since that date or
just under half of the population
required to successfully contain the
object though unclear in 1957 it is now
scientifically demonstrated that
totalitarian indoctrination may be
recreated under laboratory conditions
with relatively little sophisticated
intervention by researchers see Zimbardo
p on obedience to Authority our failure
to do so is an ethical failure of
catastrophic proportions the majority
opinion on this review declined to
authorize experimentation into
artificial totalitarianism on the
necessary scale citing both practical
and ethical concerns they believe that
it would be unacceptable to create a
totalitarian society and miniature to
prevent the end of all mankind but in
order to avoid creating an ethical
disaster in miniature we have authorized
one writ large totalitarianism which
selects individuals by a birthright
lottery and not by any particular
antisocial acts as recent events in the
USSR and elsewhere have demonstrated
totalitarian dictatorship is not a
necessary feature of society it is a
phase of development which occurred and
will someday pass and that is not the
foundations right nor even its duty to
permanently arrest the
of the North Korean people for some
greater good no matter how great that
good may be the majority are
demonstrably correct that taking
appropriate action to contain a Seabee
14:27 would involve extraordinary moral
compromises by the foundation
whereas mere abdication of our
responsibility shares this ethical
burden with all humanity and the North
Korean leadership but when we signed our
recruiting paperwork we consented to
bear that burden to do what must be done
for the greater good no matter the cost
that we now impose this burden on the
people of North Korea
rather than shouldering it ourselves is
an unacceptable abdication of our
responsibilities as foundation employees
for the foregoing reasons we the
undersigned descent reserving the right
to appeal this decision to the l5
Council s CP 1427 ACR to summary
archaeological report SCP 14:27 case
report Tommen Rosset a Sri April 21st
1993 file with SCP 14:27 principal
investigator Boozman Oz Magan PhD
project phase III a background following
the disputed SCP 1427 ethics committee
report of May 12 1990 105 authorized
phase 2 research towards decommissioning
or permanently deactivating SCP 14:27 as
part of the team be decommissioning
initiative l5 rescinded standing order
751 to 8 which prohibited foundation
members from disturbing archaeological
sites belonging to the Pleistocene
afro-asiatic culture group P a CG
following the orders revocation MTF ro
293 a lahar OGG responded excavating the
site where SCP 14 27 was believed to
originate 71 km/h OCT
discussion originally discovered by
aerial radiographic survey in 1967 the
tamanrasset asuri was cataloged and
monitored as a PA cg archeological
anomaly and assigned low containment
priority due to its minimal consensus
risk upon arrival at the site in
February of 1992 row 293 found the site
substantially undisturbed and the
radiological hazard intact deep soil
strata analysis discovered high levels
of Trinitite PD 107 u-233 u-235 Pugh 239
and radioactive decay products
consistent with an incomplete fission
event roughly 70,000 years prior to the
site's discovery this failure of nuclear
fission appears consistent with samples
taken from the kyshtym containment area
after the failed detonation of the
Soviet failsafe device the central site
occupies a single blast crater of
roughly 0.75 kilometers in diameter
centered on a rectangular depression
indicating the existence of a subsurface
structure disturbance of soil strata
indicates that SCP 1427 was likely
removed from this subsurface structure
at some time prior to the year 1600 ad
in addition the site appears to have
been disturbed both before and after the
removal of SCP 14 27 site containment
appears to have successfully been
maintained after 1967 apart from a CP 14
27 no intact artifacts were retrieved
from the central area of this site like
other PA CG sites intact artifacts
remains and complete texts appear to
have been systematically destroyed by
later sapiens sapiens populations except
where object size or durability made
deconstruction impractical the
peripheral area occupies a single
undisturbed geological strata indicating
continuous low intensity occupation
between approximately 70 1000 BC and
68,000 to be seen
artifacts recovered from the site
display features common to other PA cg
sites including the following
characteristics substantial radiological
contamination midden deposition and
ostry contents indicating substantial
infant mortality vandalism or iconoclasm
by archaic sapiens sapiens the use of
beryllium bronze is a structural
material and artifacts bearing markings
in PA cg semitic rectilinear alphabet B
remains recovered from the site indicate
cohabitation by homo sapiens idaltu and
a second unidentified hominid species
provisionally designated as Homo sapiens
dissensus relative to the hominid
baseline de census remains exhibit
gigantism and functional post axial
polydactyly with a median of six digits
per limb presuming ephemeral proportions
consistent with a human form the
subspecies median male was seven foot
six and the means female height was
seven foot two craniometry based on
recovered fragments indicates a brain
volume of roughly 520 cubic centimeters
though populations of I dolt who
increased throughout the period of
cohabitation dissensus populations
remain static above the radiation
barring geological stratum no members of
the dissensus subspecies are found
though intermittent adult to occupation
continues until approximately 63
thousand bc in approximately 61 thousand
bc non-resident adults who populations
appear to have engaged in a concerted
effort to evacuate and destroy artifacts
belonging to the PA cg culture with a
special focus on removing and destroying
de census remains as few identifying
artifacts related to later i tell to
population remain the reasons for this
period of late iconoclasm remain obscure
conclusion though the intended purpose
of SCP 14 27 remains obscure its
function appears to have been related to
the subjugation of early homo sapiens
sapiens by Homo sapiens dissensus
resistance to nuclear attack
appears to have been a high priority for
PSEG engineers all remaining PA CG
artifacts appear to have been
constructed for high resistance to
Neutron flux and many have been
recovered from what appeared to be the
sites of prehistoric nuclear attacks as
PA CG artifacts appear to directly
interfere with nuclear fission it is the
unanimous recommendation of row 293 that
decommissioning efforts focus on
conventional arms or disassembly and
that recovery of the artifact sheath or
other complete pa CG texts be made a
containment priority man a lot of
extremely in-depth scientific
terminology in this one up anyway thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to permit the reclusive extrovert James
Saba arbiter Sewell Tyler Sean
Justin day Oh philia gray Durham Curie
kuma and jayvo Jack
Jonathan Augusto and dr. Proctor thank
you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Volgin thank you
you
you